in Africa's most populous country things
are looking up for years Nigeria has
been wrecked by violence from Boko Haram
almost half of the population lives in
poverty
tensions persist between his primarily
Islamic north and the collision south
but despite all that Nigeria is on the
rise it now has the largest economy on
the continent surpassing South Africa in
2013 sixty-three percent of Nigerians
are under 25 and in 2050 the country is
expected to out populate the United
States in Nigeria oil and gas are King
accounting for 96% of the country's
export revenue Nigeria's film industry
Hollywood puts out more movies than any
other country except India Nigerians are
becoming increasingly middle-class they
now drink more champagne than anyone
outside of France the government has
invested heavily in e-commerce and the
startups in attracting big investors
like IBM and Microsoft and many
Nigerians living abroad are now
returning home to take advantage of new
opportunities
starting in February aj+ will focus on
Africa and talk to Millennials who are
making a difference there once those
stories that